My husband's favorite cookies are Milano,
so I asked our Bella if she would make him some
while I did my red light therapy.
So I got started right away.
I started by making my cookie dough consisting of all purpose
regeneratively grown flour,
unrefined salt,
and got my Kitchen Aid stand mixer set up with a paddle attachment.
I then sifted maple sugar using a fine mesh sieve
for a soft consistency.
I press the sugar through while sifting constant to my mixer.
I added in the sifted maple sugar room temperature butter,
one egg, two whites,
and vanilla. Lastly the flour and salts.
Great! Next
I added my cookie dough into a piping bag
to create the oval Milano cookies.
I fill a baking sheet by piping 2 inch cookies
and let those bake
while I get started on my chocolate ganache filling.
Using a double boiler,
I first melt the good ingredient dark chocolate chips,
then stir in some raw cream.
Consistency is smooth and silky and perfect.
Cookies come together effortlessly
by spreading ganache on the bottom cookie first,
then pushing the top cookie down.
I've never had a Milano before,
but this looks just like the cookie my father described to me
from his childhood dreams.
As a kid, he would dunk them in milk
and let them soften before consuming the entire packet.
Which doesn't surprise me
because they're also processed and highly addictive.